magie divine le monde du show you tube
au début du 14e siècle inscrite parisien
nicolas flamel fait un rêve étrange un
ange lui apparaît et lui montre une
série de symboles et d'image curieuse
ces images dit il renferme le secret de
la fabrication d'un élixir une potion
magique qui a le pouvoir de transformer
les métaux vils en or pur
e
à la suite de ce rêve nicolas flamel
rejoindra le cercle secret de ces hommes
et ces femmes du monde entier qui vouent
leur vie à la recherche d'un élixir
magique et insaisissable on les appelle
les alchimistes
l'alchimie aux flammes elles tout
commence par un rêve dans lequel un an
je lui montre un livre sans texte
uniquement constitué d'imagés
mystérieuse on raconte que quelques
temps plus tard nicolas flamel est tombé
par hasard sur un disque semblable à
celui de son rêve et l'a acheté
la couverture était une gravure au
couleur singulière avec des personnages
étranges
givi aussi des caractères qui m'étaient
inconnues
à l'intérieur se trouvaient 21 une
illustration
l'une d'entre elles représentant un
serpent crucifié
cela s'applique dès lors à décrypter ces
symboles avec sa femme père noël il
passe par at-il 25 ans a tenté de percer
les secrets de l'alchimie est à chercher
le moyen de transmuter des métaux vils
en or pur sa quête le mène aux quatre
coins du monde
il se rend au maroc et en espagne pour
rencontrer des mystiques juifs qui
connaissent la plupart des symboles dont
il tente de saisir le sens flamme elle
consacre sa vie à la poursuite du réveil
chimique puis un jour la rumeur se
répand en france que flamme elle a
atteint son but
enfin j'ai trouvé ce que je cherchais je
l' ai vite compris à la forte odeur qui
se dégageait de ma préparation
à partir de ce moment là j'ai appris
sans difficulté à connaître et à
maîtriser cette matière
après 25 ans de travail acharné flamme
rsa femmes connaissent enfin le succès
et accumule dit on des richesses
inestimables
il faut qu'ils ont très généreux aux
églises et aux hôpitaux sur la légende a
tendance a dû passer la réalise ainsi
longtemps après leur mort on raconte que
flamme est de sa femme vivait encore une
centaine d'années plus tard dans
différents pays d'europe
certains témoins affirment les avoir
aperçus après leur mort leur maison est
mise à sac dans l'espoir de percer leur
secret mais ils les ont emportés dans la
seconde
or quatre cents ans après sa mort des
témoins affirment toujours l'avoir vu
vivant désormais le mythe de
l'immortalité de flamme elle est née on
prête aux alchimistes tous les pouvoirs
celui de changer les métaux en or voire
même celui d'atteindre la vie éternelle
la sagesse qui a inspiré flamel et les
autres alchimiste européen provient de
l'antiquité et en particulier de
l'ancienne egypte où des artisans
d'inventer un art tenu secret qui
inspire à la fois la crainte et le
respect chimie occidentale prend ses
racines dans l'egypte ancienne et l'on
peut considérer les alchimistes de cette
époque comme des précurseurs de la
chimie moderne
les alchimistes de l'antiquité invente
des techniques de peinture de coulage de
bronzage du métal il fabrique également
des bijoux des parfums et savent surtout
embaumer les corps des morts et dans
l'au delà
c'est de l'or que les égyptiens tiennent
à emporter avec eux
et non 10 heures les sens et is good
sexting dans toutes les sociétés
antilles ont estimé costa lors revêt une
grande importance
sans doute en raison de son inaltérable
ilité il type seulement miss pour
assurer leur immortalité
on recouvre d'or les masques des momies
égyptiennes coenguen l'onglet vtt
compact ou si l'on remonte au tout début
de l'alchimie à dire au travail des
métaux par les égyptiens
on remarque qu'ils cherchent eux aussi
un style mittelland et king mat au look
like convaincu qu'un états qui ressemble
à de l'or looks like on possède
également les vertus qu'on maquille
secondes
ainsi lorsque les premiers alchimiste
échouent dans leurs tentatives de
transformer le métal ville en or il
dessine faute de mieux
d'employés tout leur talent à imiter
leurs véritables d'autres civilisations
antiques comme les grecs et les romains
se lancent à leur tour dans l'aventuré
et le iiième siècle voit éclore l'âge
d'or de l'alchimie
à cette époque les étudiants en alchimie
sont si nombreux qu une académie est
fondée par le plus brillant d'entre eux
zosime de panneaux police zosime sera le
premier à parler de cette pierre qui
n'est pas une bière de cette mystérieuse
substance doté de pouvoirs magiques la
pierre philosophale
elle devient dès lors le saint graal des
alchimistes
partant du principe que des éléments de
base peuvent donner naissance à de
nouvelles matières par exemple le bois
en brûlant des gages de l'eau puis de la
fumée et enfin devient cendres de même
le plan pourrait se transformer en or
sous certaines conditions
mais l'académie d'alchimie devient
bientôt une véritable école de
contrefaçon son succès si rapide que ses
étudiants inonde bientôt le marché de
savant alliage de cuivre de plomb et
d'heures qu'ils font passer pour de l'or
pur
cette pratique entraîne la chute du
cours de l'or en réaction l'empereur
romain dioclétien fait brûler tous les
ouvrages d'alchimie de la grande
bibliothèque d'alexandrie
en même temps que ses livres ce sont de
nombreux secrets alchimique détenus par
les égyptiens et le monde antique qui
partent en fumée
au viiie siècle c'est dans le monde
oriental que l'on voit émerger
d'importants paul intellectuels comme
bagdad en irak ont fès au maroc de
nouveaux enseignements et de nouvelles
idées voit le jour
des oeuvres antiques majeurs sont alors
traduite et pendant les sept siècles qui
suivent les villes orientales deviennent
deux hauts lieux de la pensée
les écoles et les universités où l'on
enseigne et jusque là la théologie
s'ouvre alors à de nouvelles sciences
comme les mathématiques et l'astronomie
les arabes contribuer tout
particulièrement à développer la science
elle chimiques
mais la quête de l'or se révèle toujours
aussi vaines et les nombreux à chimiste
arabes se tourne alors vers d'autres
disciplines telles que la médecine
il commence à mener des expériences avec
un grand nombre de produits chimiques
avec des métaux des sulfures et des
selles il modernise les techniques de
distillation et de calcination
oh
il ne renonce pas pour autant à leurs
rêves mais en attendant leur métal
fétiche le mercure sert davantage à
guérir les maladies courantes qu'à
fabriquer de l'or
au 12e siècle leurs arts occultes gagne
l'europe
ils apportent avec eux de nouveaux
termes scientifiques alcool alkali
alambic élixir et enfin le mot alchimie
lui-même de l'arabe al kenya l'art de
fondre et d'allier les métaux dans un
moyen âge où l'église est toute
puissante
lorsque l'alchimie se répand en europe
c'est une véritable science qui dépasse
la simple manipulation chimiques
elle est alors très suspecte au regard
de leur taux doxique chrétienne
moyen-âge
l'alchimie prend une dimension
spirituelle et devient une doctrine
ajouté les alchimistes continuent leurs
recherches de la fortune magique
susceptibles de transformer les métaux
vils en argent cette recherche est
intimement liée à leur propre quête
spirituelle qui passe par la
purification de l'âme pour pouvoir
purifier des métaux vils les alchimistes
convaincu de la perfection de l'âme
humaine se purifie le même en s'imposant
des multiples épreuves ce qui leur
permet d'atteindre la plénitude
spirituel de passer de l'ombre à la
lumière
en attendant cette purification les uns
espèrent toujours transformer les métaux
vils en or les autres en revanche
pensent que cette fameuse pierre
philosophale possède bien d'autres
pouvoir prolonger la vie
ou mieux encore rendre immortel comme ce
fut peut-être le cas pour la mère
ndaw est et nestlé au début les
alchimistes occidentaux procède à de
nombreuses manipulations comme la
distillation la combustion ou la fusion
de la matière c'est ainsi qu'il découvre
l'alcool regardez quel effet l'alcool
produit sur les hommes ils sont
persuadés d'avoir découvert l'élixir de
vie
cette découverte vote à ses auteurs une
célébrité immédiate au xiiie siècle
arnaud de villeneuve un alchimiste
français invente un breuvage
révolutionnaire composé d'or et d'alcool
sa potion connaît un tel succès que le
pape clément convaincu que ce savant a
découvert le secret de l'immortalité le
fait venir à rome
mais il semble que cet élixir ne possède
pas toutes les vertus que le pape lui
prête
car arnaud de villeneuve meurt
subitement pendant le voyage qui le
mènent à rome
ce malheureux événement ne décourage pas
pour autant les autres alchimiste
européen
toujours en quête du précieux métal
le plus célèbres pionniers de l'alchimie
et le suisse paracelse dont les
brillantes recherches vont dépasser la
simple quête de l'or
paracels se passe sa jeunesse à
manipuler bon nombre de substances
nouvelles
et comme les autres alchimiste il tente
de fabriquer de l'or à partir des métaux
vils
mais paracels se décrète finalement que
l'art de guérir et sans doute plus
important que la quête de l'or ont dit
que l'alchimie sert à fabriquer l'or et
l'argent
pour moi le principal but de l'alchimie
est d'étudier les vertus et les pouvoirs
des remèdes
de son vrai nom c'est aux frasques
combat se fait appeler paracelse
présente il
il est meilleure que celle ci le célèbre
médecin roumain il mais l'alchimie et
l'astrologie au service de la médecine
stores la dgi et commence à élaborer
cette nouvelle science et bientôt
baptisé ya trop chiche autrement dit
plutôt que de chercher à fabriquer deux
heures ou à découvrir la fameuse formule
celle ci utilise ses connaissances
alchimique au profit de la recherche
scientifique inps shox ces remèdes
devienne bientôt célèbre dans toute
l'europe
il est le premier à considérer
l'épilepsie comme une maladie et non
plus comme une forme de folie
il est également le premier a
diagnostiqué la syphilis et à la traiter
avec un composé de mercure que les
médecins prescriront encore quelques 400
ans plus tard
il découvre également le laudanum un
dérivé de l'opium utilisé comme
analgésique
mais il le 16e siècle est néanmoins une
période dangereuse tant pour les
médecins que pour les alchimistes accusé
de charlatanisme et de sorcellerie
ils se voient contraints d'exercer leur
art dans la clandestinité sous peine
d'avoir à se défendre âprement contre
leurs détracteurs
mais paracelse est sans doute celui qui
répond le plus virulent ment aux
critiques qu'on lui adresse
laissez moi vous dire une chose le plus
petit de mes cheveux et plus savant que
vous et tous vos scribe réunis et ma
barbe a plus d'expérience que toutes vos
grandes écoles
ces attaques contre les scientifiques et
l'utilisation qu'il fait de ces étranges
remède lui valent beaucoup d'ennemis
il sauve la vie du savant hollandais
erasme et de plusieurs autres
personnalités gagnant ainsi leur
protection pour un certain temps après
avoir violemment calomnier des
magistrats il est contraint de partir et
devient vagabond il meurt à salzburg en
autriche dans le plus parfait dénuement
il a 48 ans
par nécessité les alchimistes se
replient sur eux-mêmes et exerce
désormais leur art dans le plus grand
secret pourtant occasionnellement
quelques éminents savants accorde du
crédit à leur recherche
robert boyle le grand scientifique
irlandais du xviie siècle considéré
comme l'un des inventeurs de la chimie
moderne manifestent un grand intérêt
pour l'alchimie avec l'un de ses
assistants allemands ils découvrent une
matière étrange
le phosphore
les manuscrits retrouvés après sa mort
révèle clairement la passion secrète
qu'il vouait à l'alchimie l'un de ses
écrits hermétique et rédigé dans un
langage si complexe que personne n'a été
jusqu'à ce jour capable de le déchiffrer
aujourd'hui encore des chercheurs de
l'université américaine john hopkins
travail sur les milliers de pages
écrites par boyle jusqu'ici ces textes
défi la compréhension
une partie du problème réside dans le
fait que l'art des alchimistes ne
consiste pas uniquement à mélanger des
produits chimiques
l'alchimie fait également appel à des
rites et des symboles complexe les
alchimistes voit dans les substances
qu'il fabrique davantage que le sac le
composent et obtenu par réaction
chimique à leurs yeux ces mixtures sont
chargés d'un sens un sens purement
métaphorique ou encore symboliques ou
religieux
cet aspect a totalement disparaît bien
sûr de la chimie moderne mais était très
présent dans l'esprit des premiers
alchimiste
ainsi de la même manière que les écrits
des alchimistes sont codées leur langage
pictural regorge de sens caché de secret
détenu par les anciens et transmis de
génération en génération des symboles
tels que le soleil les animaux
mythologiques les rois et les reines
sont fréquemment employés et possède un
pouvoir certain
lorsqu'on les interprètes correctement
notre santé oms ont des connaissances
des alchimistes se transmettent de
bouche à oreille et grâce à des textes
codifié selon des règles précises est
tenue secrète mais également par le
biais d'illustration
la chimie les images souvent ambiguës
ont une importance considérable
en fait il existe des textes et
hermétique rédigés dans un langage
strictement pictural avance ainsi le
seul moyen de les décoder revient à
consulter un alchimiste comme moi
pourrons saisir le sens respectives
le rouge symbolise le soleil et le blanc
l'argent symbolise la lune réunit ces
deux astres forme d'un symbole clé en
alchimie dans de nombreuses
illustrations par exemple on les voit se
fondre se rejoindre pour former la
pierre philosophale symbole de la
perfection stop sous les couleurs
utilisées sur les alchimistes revêt
également une importance considérable de
noir d'une valeur inférieure aux autres
couleurs symbolisent la mort vient
ensuite le blanc et enfin le rouge
depuis l'émergence de leur art aux
alentours du 3ème siècle après
jésus-christ jusqu'au xviie siècle ces
alchimistes travaillent d'arrache-pied à
l'élaboration d'un langage symbolique
l'alchimie est une quête spirituelle
un parcours initiatique une
interprétation allégorique de la
mythologie
selon moi la tradition de la pensée
occidentale veut que plus les vérités
essentielles des vérités religieuses
sont exprimés en langage complexe plus
nous sommes à même d'en saisir
l'importance
les manuscrits hermétique regorge de
symboles étrange l'image violente
dérangeante sur rennes l'une des plus
belles et des plus spectaculaires série
d'illustrations alchimique se trouve
dans le très précieux manuscrits de la
british library
l'un des trésors de cette aiguille il a
pour titre la splendeur du soleil et
contient 22 planches illustrant de
manière très énigmatique et curieuse les
procédés alchimique ici sur la première
nous voyons un alchimiste absorbée par
une expérience sur le parchemin au
dessus de lui on peut lire partons à la
recherche de l'origine des quatre
éléments
d'autres mystiques ont repris bon nombre
de symboles alchimique pour développer
leur propre doctrine ésotérique
on en retrouve certains dans un célèbre
jeu de cartes divinatoire le tarot
en tant que discipline spirituelle
l'alchimie se développe aux alentours du
12e siècle et le tarot apparaît quelques
centaines d'années plus tard toutes les
figures du tarot sont inspirés de
symbole chimique et ont une
signification exotérique
first jack sparrow date du milieu du 14e
siècle
à l'origine ces cartes avait sans doute
une fonction d monique et servait à
retenir des formules médicinales ou à
représenter certains types caractériel
certaine classe sociale
c'est aux alentours du xviie siècle
qu'est né le jeu de société divinatoires
aujourd'hui connu sous le nom de tarot
mais les ouest il existe de nombreuses
manières d'utiliser le taser la plus
répandue est temps de placer les cartes
dans un ordre précis afin qu'elles
forment une figure particulière chaque
carte indépendamment de sa position
possède une signification propre le plus
souvent un chimiques par essence ce qui
laisse à penser que d un chimiste ont
participé à l'élaboration du tableau par
exemple attiré la carte du pendule n'est
pas un présage de mort comme tend à le
penser certaines personnes
en fait cette carte possède une
signification hautement symbolique est
très haché mais dans le sens où la mort
est synonyme de changement
c'est à dire l'apparition d'un nouvel
ordre qui fait place à l'ancien
il n'est pas étonnant que le symbole
chimique de la mort soit omniprésent
dans l'impressionnante architecture
pragoise aux 15e et 16e siècles prague
devient la mecque des alchimistes du
monde entier et un peu partout dans la
ville
de nombreux monuments porte la trace de
leur passage
prague est une ville réputée pour son
dynamisme culturel qui abrite nombre de
musiciens poètes et artistes
très vite elle attire les plus célèbres
et chimistes européens
à l'époque dans la plupart des pays
d'europe les mystiques et les devins
tels que nostradamus ou les alchimistes
comme bassel ce sont suspects aux yeux
de l'église une église toute puissante
et influente auprès des rois princes des
dirigeants européens
mais prague fait exception
dans la capitale du saint-empire romain
germanique les empereurs qui y règne
domine le clergé local au 16e siècle
ils réussissent à endormir les soupçons
de l'église à l'égard des mystiques et
des alchimistes afin de céder à leur
propre fascination pour l'ésotérisme
tous les alchimistes qui s'installe à
prague et chattes à la persécution
religieuse mais s'ils échouent dans
leurs tentatives de fabriquer lors il se
voit infliger de sévères punitions
en revanche s'ils ont une quelconque
chance de réussir on leur offre à la
cour une existence de ré rodolphe deux
saintes empereur romain germanique roi
de bavière et d'autriche règne en maître
sur cette renaissance de l'alchimie
fantaisistes et poète à ses heures il
accueille les alchimistes à bras ouverts
et mieux encore financent leurs rêves
rodolphe est un fervent collectionneur
de curiosité du monde entier dans ses
appartements
on trouve aussi bien des creusé à poison
que des échantillons de terre de la
vallée d'hébron où dieu aurait créé adam
il possède aussi des milliers d'horloge
des globes construit par les plus grand
cartographe européen et une vaste
collection de livres scientifiques
comprenant également des ouvrages de
sciences occultes
un sujet qui le fascine rats toute sa
vie
roland 50 détente en run off 2 m'invite
pas seulement des alchimistes à la
course mais aussi des orfèvres des
peintres et autres artisans
il aime la peinture et surtout les
oeuvres d'art team bordeaux un artiste
qui exécutent des portraits mais composé
de fruits et de poissons fichiers soient
pacifiques
l'un d'entre eux comprend 65 espèces de
poissons composants d'un visage hideux
aussi nationale
il s'intéresse lui aussi à l'alchimie et
les couleurs qui l'utilisent font partie
du langage alchimique il réalise
notamment apporter de rodolphe ii avec
des fleurs et les roses
la couleur dominante est le rouge parce
que le rouge est une couleur noble
à
dans cette société bigarrée on trouve
autant de savants en quête de vérité que
de charlatans et d'un poster à la cour
de rodolphe deux vivent non moins de 200
alchimiste qui rivalisent de gloire et
de fortune
rodolphe les héberge tous dans la
célèbre rue des alchimistes où vit à la
fin du xvième siècle john dit l'ancien
astrologue de la reine elizabeth 1re
d'angleterre son honorable carrière
prend fin lorsqu'il s'associe à un
charlatan du nom d' edward kelly
et c'est times à cette époque des
alchimistes uniquement poussé par
l'appât du gain comme m
edward que les a ou à tin tin côtoient
des mystiques comme john dit que ces
deux personnages sont alors si
intimement ligne qui partagent même
leurs femmes
ce qu'il considère comme l'aspect le
plus agréable de la philosophie rim
éthiques
en tout état de cause tous ces
personnages mais quand prague l'amex et
sashimis la ville de rodez 2
s'intéressent à tous les aspects de
l'alchimie qu'il s'agisse de
métaphysique ou de spiritualité mais
également à l'aspect le plus occulte de
ces tares la fabrication de l'or pour
s'enrichir
john dee et edward kelly comme beaucoup
d'autres alchimiste finissent par
prendre refuge dans cette cour sans
jamais parvenir bien sûr à produire le
moindre gramme d'or edward kelly quant à
lui est un faussaire confirme en
angleterre il a déjà connu la prison et
la torture
pourtant il parvient par la ruse à
s'attirer les faveurs de rodolphe 2 qui
le fait chevalier et lui donne toute
licence pour fabriquer ce métal tant
convoité lors
où
non
kelly extrait alors du charbon auxquels
ils ajoutent des pépites d'or de sorte
que lorsqu'il fait sa démonstration
devant rodolphe de ce dernier est
convaincu que son protégé vient de
découvrir la fameuse formule
il y déclare vous voyez majesté shakey
si j'ai réussi à fabriquer de l'homme si
vous me donner beaucoup d'argent je
pourrais en produire 60 ou même 100 fois
plus lorsque rodolphe lui demande
combien de temps il a besoin
il répond au nom ce qui lui vaut d'être
logique une année entière la cour où il
ne fera que de rares ici mais la
patience de rodolphe tous mécènes qu'il
soit a des limites
sous son règne plus d'un faussaire a
fini dans les geôles de son château
et
un jour c'est le tour de kelly sa chance
a tourné rodolphe ii le fait jeter en
prison où il meurt quelques temps plus
tard
à la même époque d'autres alchimiste
européen qui se rendent coupables
d'escroquerie sont brûlés pendu ou
emprisonnés l'un d'entre eux un
compagnon de kelly subi un châtiment
exemplaire
il est habillé de guirlandes dorées et
pendu au bout d'une corde jaune jusqu'à
ce que mort s'ensuive
en dépit de tous ses efforts pour
financer soutenir les alchimistes
rodolphe ii n'obtiendra jamais lors
qu'il cherche si désespérément pourtant
bien des siècles plus tard des
archéologues feront une découverte que
rodolphe aurait sans doute accueillie
avec la plus grande joie en exhumant ces
restes ils les ont trouvés dans un
remarquable état de conservation
étrangement les habits rouges dans
lesquelles rodolphe ii avait dit ont été
enterrées étaient devenus d'auray
la mort de rodolphe ii ne sonne en aucun
cas le glas de l'alchimie désormais
c'est en angleterre qu'elle trouve son
plus fervent défenseur
un scientifique de grande renommée
ceci est le pommier le plus célèbre du
monde
en 1666 selon la légende une pomme est
tombé au pied d'un jeune homme assis
dans le jardin de sa mère à cambridge
grâce à cette pomme isaac newton entame
alors une série d'expériences qui le
mèneront à la découverte de la théorie
de la gravitation
à l'âge de 24 ans newton devient le
mathématicien le plus en vue de toute
l'europe avant de jeter les bases de sa
théorie dans l' ouvrage qui lui vaudra
une réputation mondiale principia et
mathématiques à
dans les appartements de sa mère il mène
également des expériences sur la lumière
en utilisant des prismes
il consacre le reste de sa longue et
brillante existence à rendre compte de
ses travaux sur la lumière et la
gravitation au cours de conférences
mais les livres scientifiques modernes
passe souvent sous silence un autre
aspect de ces travaux en effet newton
s'adonner secrètement à l'alchimie
aujourd'hui il nous paraît étonnant que
quelqu'un comme newton ait pu
s'intéresser aux sciences occultes
mais pour un physicien du xviie siècle
vale chimie est une partie du monde un
domaine de connaissances qu'il est
important d'explorer et de comprendre
pour newton convaincu de l'existence de
la prise tina sapienza une sagesse
antique donnée par dieu à dents ou à ses
fils et transmise ensuite à sa
descendance
l'alchimie revêtent une signification
particulière ainsi si nous voulons avoir
du monde une connaissance profonde
le mieux est encore de se référer à la
parole même de retrouver cette parole
il faut renouer avec la prestine à sa
pièce cette sagesse antique et newton
considère l'alchimie comme l'un des
moyens d'y parvenir
newton possède plus de 200 ouvrages
l'alchimie venant du monde entier dont
il se sert pour ses expériences ses
recherches personnelles
on
wakamatsu mais il ne faut pas oublier
qu'au xviie siècle tous les lettrés
s'intéresse d'une manière ou d'une autre
à l'alchimie qui écrit sur ce sujet des
centaines de pages ne fait pas exception
à la règle
ils passent 30 ans dans son laboratoire
à tester inlassablement toutes sortes de
formules mais n'abandonne pas pour
autant la pratique de l'alchimie sa mort
cette science connaît un tel déclin de
newton jouit d'un tel prestige que sa
famille convaincue que la révélation de
sa passion secrète risque de ternir sa
réputation fait disparaître tous ses
manuscrits alchimie
l'un des derniers grands savants a tenté
de remettre l'alchimie au goût du jour
et le très respectable james pryce un
jeune chimiste anglais
en 1781 2 après avoir travaillé quelques
années dans son laboratoire personnel
price prétend avoir découvert la formule
d'une poudre blanche pouvant donner
jusqu'à 50 fois son poids en argent et
d'une poudre rouge pouvant donner 60
fois son poids en or il présente sa
méthode devant une assemblée d'éminents
savants ces travaux deviennent si
célèbres qu'ils sont traduits en 107
langues
des échantillons de l'or ainsi obtenus
sont exhibés à la cour du roi george iii
d'angleterre
mais c'est que la grèce est sceptique
est le plus éminent savant anglais de
l'époque sur joseph bank's insiste pour
que price défendent l'honneur de la
science en démontrant ce qu'il avance
devant un comité d'experts impartiaux en
août 1783 trois experts se rendent au
domicile de price pour assister à sa
démonstration le chimiste reçoit
calmement ses visiteurs avant de
reprendre la préparation de ces poudres
alchimique
alors que les savants sont occupés à
vérifier ses préparations
il avale de l'eau de laurier cerise un
poison mortel s'effondre et meurt sur le
champ
ses obsèques ont lieu dans une église
locale et l'on graves sur sa pierre
tombale l'épitaphe haut comme il s'est
trompé
alors que messing chimie semble avoir
disparu progressivement en allemagne
elle perdure jusque vers 1580 et l'on
continuera même pendant quelques années
d'un prix mais certains textes
hermétique
en revanche en france comme en
angleterre cette science est la risée de
tous dès les années 1730 et en 1740 elle
sombre dans l'oubli
mais lors des trois derniers siècles
l'alchimiste ont peu à peu en désuétude
on ignore les symboles et on daigne ces
savants cupide désireux de faire
rapidement fortune en transformant du
plomb en heure en d'autres termes
l'alchimie est très décrié et ses
adeptes sont tournés en ridicule
on pourrait penser qu'à l'époque où la
raison scientifique triomphe
l'alchimie seraient relégués au rang des
bizarreries de l'histoire est jetée aux
oubliettes
mais étrangement elle prend après le 18e
siècle un essor inattendue à l'instar de
nicolas flamel qui en vain à explorer
l'univers hermétique par le rêve il ya
600 ans
un psychiatre suisse du 20e siècle
rejoint par les mêmes voies l'alchimie
il s'appelle carl jung
car lyon grâce à ses propres rêves
commencent à s'intéresser à l'alchimie
car les rêves et les visions sont l'une
des principales sources d'inspiration
des alchimistes
ils maintiennent ainsi leur découverte
secrète en les consignes ans dans un
langage symbolique et picturale
une nuit youm fait un rêve qui va
changer sa vie il se trouve dans une
maison dont il découvre une aile secret
ce qu'ils se mettent à explorer
e
les white house lifois une superbe
bibliothèque pleine de livres contenant
des symboles qui ne comprend pas mais
qui le fascine
e
hamel un beau jour on lui offre un
ouvrage d'alchimie il s'écrie seigneur
quelle sottise comment peut-on croire à
une chose pareille mais en même temps
ces patients continuelle vais raconter
des rêves qu'il ne parvient pas
interpréter ou des aigles volders deux
directions à la fois et lui rapporte des
visions d'une femme debout sur une
mappemonde
cela est d'autant plus intriguant qu'il
prend un texte et le lit sans le
comprendre
puis soudain l'existence d'un langage
onirique constitué de symboles lui
apparaît comme une évidence
et cette découverte qui confirme à ses
yeux l'idée que le rêve est profondément
ancré dans la nature humaine le frappe
énormément
il faut dire que ces études mythologique
l'ont préparé à développer une pensée
symbolique une pensée qu'il considère
comme essentielles à la compréhension de
notre inconscient et de nos rêves j'ai
mis beaucoup de temps à quitter les
méandres de la pensée alchimique
en étudiant un texte du 16e siècle j'ai
remarqué que certains symboles
revenaient fréquemment mais je ne
parvenais pas à en décrypter le sens
c'était comme si je cherchais à résoudre
un rébus formulées dans un langage
inconnu
cette tâche mme a absorbé pendant plus
de dix ans
oh
les rêves joue un rôle primordial en
alchimie pour la simple raison qu'ils
sont la principale source d'inspiration
de telles choses il croit fermement au
pouvoir révélateur des rays qui leur
permet d'accéder à la sagesse et de
mieux maîtriser leur art les rêves sont
constitués de symboles mystérieux et par
là-même alchimique nous rêvons toutes
les nuits et nos rêves sont plaint d'
images mystérieuses dans le sens nous
est le plus souvent un comme les
alchimistes étudie des symboles dont
seuls quelques initiés connaissent la
signification
c'était cela leur univers young
l'observent alors une analogie entre les
images oniriques de ses patients et les
symboles alchimique même si ces patients
n'ont jamais entendu parler de
l'alchimie et ignore tout de ses
symboles leurs représentations lyriques
sont semblables à celles des manuscrits
hermétique et l'interprétation de leurs
rêves confirme la nature alchimique de
ses symboles
puis youm découvre avec satisfaction que
les travaux des alchimistes de la chine
ancienne recoupe ses propres travaux
c'est avec un intérêt accru qui comprend
alors que l'alchimie orientale
contrairement à l'alchimie occidental
est demeurée intacte à travers les
siècles
bien avant que les premiers alchimiste
européens commencent à construire leur
laboratoire secret les magiciens et les
mystiques de la chine ancienne étaient
déjà convaincus qu'ils pouvaient
fabriquer de l'or à partir d'autres
substances au 2e siècle avant
jésus-christ un grand alchimiste de la
cour de l'empereur outils déclare je
sais comment le cinabre change de nature
pour se transformer en or je peux
chevaucher le dragon volant est allé au
bout du monde je peux grimper à
califourchon sur sa tête et franchir les
neuf marches qui mènent au paradis si
vous procédez vous aussi à des
sacrifices sur le bûcher
alors vous pourrez transformer le
cinabre en or
les alchimistes chinois prétendent que
l'or a également des effets bénéfiques
sur le corps humain les premiers
alchimiste chinois conseille aux gens de
bois de l'or un peu plus tard il
préconise des substances guillon la
couleur et l'aspect de la vieux c'est
combien de gens sont morts mais valence
et breuvages mais les chinois ont
rapidement arrêté de boire de l'or pour
prolonger la vie
ils ont préféré à faire de l'exercice
physique théorique une sorte de yoga il
y a une différence fondamentale entre
l'alchimie occidentale et l'alchimie
orientale la première a d'abord eu pour
but la quête de l'or tandis que l'autre
aspirait à l'immortalité
traditionnellement l'alchimie chinoise a
pour but atteindre l'immortalité par la
purification de l'âme pour parvenir à ce
niveau supérieur il faut connaître
certains processus posséder la formule
de mystérieuses et lexie maîtriser des
techniques de respiration gâteux et
s'astreindre à des exercices physiques
partant de chine la philosophie
hermétique se propage par les anciennes
routes commerciales jusqu'au coeur de
l'inde
il y a près de deux mille ans des
alchimistes du tamil nadu à l'extrême
sud de l'inde utilisait de l'or ou des
substances que l'on prenait pour de l'or
dans un rituel magique destiné à
conférer l'immortalité
l'une des plus anciennes prière de cette
époque dit l'orne et du feu est celui
qui le porte est immortel étrangement la
méthode inventée par les alchimistes
indien de l'antiquité a survécu jusqu'à
nos jours
l'élixir magique des alchimistes ne peut
être préparée qu'une fois l'an dans un
site secret c'est sur ce site que l'on
trouve l'un des ingrédients
indispensables à l'élaboration de cette
potion cette poudre qui n'apparaît
qu'une seule fois par an par une nuit de
pleine lune n'est visible qu'à minuit
cette poudre s'appelle le pané roues
selon les alchimistes c'est l'attraction
lunaire qui l'a fait remonter des
entrailles jusqu'à la surface de la
terre
le panneau où est l'ingrédient essentiel
de leur potion magique qui contient
également des métaux tels que le mercure
l'argent le zinc et le plomb
pour les alchimistes indien ne pas nehru
supprime tous les effets indésirables
des préparations alchimique et l'élixir
qu'on en tire à la vertu de prolonger la
vie
en inde et en asie certains alchimiste
sont convaincus que les rêves de leurs
prédécesseurs de l'antiquité n'étaient
pas des chimères
tout simplement ils ne se sont pas
encore réalisés
en europe on poursuit aujourd'hui
d'autres rêves mais là aussi alchimie
antique et sciences contemporaines
semble avoir trouvé un terrain d'entente
qui lui des croyances fondamentales les
alchimistes et la transmutation
c'est à dire la transformation des
métaux vils en or curieusement c'est ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui je veux
dire que nous sommes maintenant capables
d'effectuer des transmutations de
transformer un élément en un autre ainsi
ironie du sort les alchimistes avait
raison
oh